またはテレサは
このように言いました
思考に気をつけなさい
それはいつか言葉になるから
言葉に気をつけなさい
それはいつか行動になるから
行動に気をつけなさい
それはいつか習慣になるから
習慣に気をつけなさい
それはいつか性格になるから
性格に気をつけなさい
それはいつか
運命になるから
マザーテレサ
思考から始まって
それがいつか運命になるとそのように言いました
今日は
運命の変え方というテーマで
何が自分自身の運命に大きな影響を与えるのかということを私自身の原体験本当に
皆さんと一緒に掘り下げて考える時間にしたいと思っています
その話をする前にまず私が育った背景を簡単にご紹介します
僕は6人家族で兄弟が4人います
ただでさえ兄弟が4人もいる上に
4人全員が私立の高校に進学したので
節約をするしかない家庭環境でした
さらに僕は光合成の時に
留学にも行けるようにしてくれ
またお小遣いもわずかしかもらっていなかったので
特に節約をするしかない
の立場でした
当時は高校生でしたが
それこそものすごく節約をしていて
例えば僕がお腹が空いてお腹がすいてコンビニ何かを買おうとしたときに
僕が会僕が支えたお金はたった100円150円しかありませんでした
その100円150円を使って
パンやおにぎり何かを食べようとしたときに
あった10円15円惜しんで何を食べようか
あれを食べたらいいのかどうやったら一番もったいなくないようにお金を使うことが
できるんだろうか
そのように10分も20分も考えて悩む時もよくありました
節約をしていたのでとにかく
もったえないことが嫌いでした
毎日毎日そのように考えながら生活をしていたので
いつのまにか自分の人生や
生き方を考えたときに同じように考えるようになっていました
どうせ人生を一度生きるなら
絶対にもったいない人生を生きたくない
最大限世の中に貢献して
最善を尽くしていきたい
人の役に立ちたい
このように考えていました
しかし自分が何か活動していたわけでもまた行動力があったわけでもありませんでした
それは逆で全く行動力もなかったし
人見知りで怖がりで
人に会うだけでも緊張して震えていました
身長も低くで頭も悪くて勉強もできなくて
自分に本当に自信がありませんでした
自分に一体どんな取り柄があるんだろうと考えることを
よくありました
しかし
どうせ人生を一度生きるなろう
絶対にもったいない人生を生きたくない
最大限世の中に貢献して
人の役に立ちたい
このように
この思いは変わりませんでした
しかし自分が突如買われたわけでもなかったし
何か行動ができたわけでもありませんでした
変われると思う
持っていませんでした
しかし
1人の人との出会いをきっかけに
そこから大きく運命が変わるようになってきました
それは僕が高校生の時に出会うようになった
先生との出会いでした
僕が今でも感謝していて一番尊敬する人です
何の特徴も何の才能を
何の能力もなかった私に
それでも人の役には立ちたい
そのように思っていた私に
先生はこのようにアドバイスをしてくれました
初めから大きいことをしようと思ってもできないから
初めは小さいことから始めてみなさい
やればできる
誰でもやればできるしやらなければできない
ただ
やるなら最後までやりなさい
このようにアドバイスをくれました
この時に
僕が得たものは
できるという認識でした
この時から先生のアドバイス通り僕は少しずつ活動を始めるようになりました
まず最初は誰にでもできるようなゴミ拾いの活動を近くの商店街に行って友達2人3人
と一緒に始めました
活動を始めて
続けて行なっていくうちに少し数参加してくれる人も増えていきながら
また1年間続けて活動して言ったら
多い時では数十人の学生たちが
さん
してくれる活動になりました
さらに商店街の組合の方とつながるようになり
地域に貢献していく活発な活動に発展していきました
さらにこの活動を続けながら
僕が大学生活を過ごしていく流れ
この大学にもっとこんな場があったらいいんじゃないかといった想いをもとに新しく
団体を立ち上げて活動を始めるようになりました
これも最初
少人数の仲間と一緒に始めた活動でしたが
1年間に年間続けて活動していくうちに
数百人の人たちが参加してくれる大きな活動になっていきました
人の役に立ちたい
と思っていた僕の願いはまだまだ小さい規模ではありますがこの活動を通して考えられ
ているような気がしています
また
もっと大きなことにチャレンジしたいと思うよなった僕は
偶然知るようになった内閣府国際交流事業というものに参加するようになりました
この事業は国と国とをつなぐ大きなプロジェクトです
全国から若者たちが集まってきてそこで組織をつくって海外に行って活動する
こういったプロジェクトです
このプロジェクトで僕は副代表を務めるようになり
1年間副代表として続けて活動しました
そしてこの活動が終わった後
報告会という形で
特別に
次の
日本の天皇になれる
皇太子さまと直接1対1でお会いしてお話する
そのような機会もありました
この一つ一つの報道また一つ一つの活動が僕にとってはかけがえのない経験となり
振り返った時には
常に僕の運命は変わっていました
認識は行動を決定する位
この時に僕が得た大きな学びです
人は
認識した通りに自分の行動を決定していきます
例えば僕のように
できると強く認識したからこそ
できた c
もしあの時先生が
君にできると言ってくれずに
君には難しいかもしれない
日々より優秀な人はもっといるそのように言っていたら僕は今も認識が変わらず
分かったでしょ
またあることが危ないと認識したら
その人は逃げるだろうし危なくないと思ったらその人にいけないでしょ
また
あることを正しいと認識したらその人は続けてそれが正しいと思って
行動して行動していくことでしょう
このように
人は
自分が認識した通りに自分の行動を決定していきます
なので
自分自身を
どのように認識するかがー
自分の運命を大きく変えていく大きな要因です
認識が変わったきっかけは環境にありました
つまり素晴らしい人との出会いがきっかけでした
世の中にはあまりにも多くの人たちがいます
この中で
どの環境に自分自身の御用金
また誰と接して生きるのかわいい
自分を変える上でものすごく重要なことです
今日は
まったく
行動力もなく
極度の人見知りデー
自分に何も取り柄がない
そのように思っていた
私が
1人の人との出会いをきっかけに
認識が変わり大きく運命を変えたという話をしました
今日のスピーチの最初に
マザーテレサの言葉をご紹介しました
まず当てるサワー
始めねー
思考に気をつけなさいと言いました
なぜならそれがいつか運命になるからです
今日の話を踏まえて
もし僕がこのマザーテレサの言葉に言葉をつけたせるとしたら
このように付け足したいと思います
環境に気をつけなさい
それはいつか認識になるから
認識に気をつけなさい
それがいつか思考になるから
最後にみなさんに問いたいと思います
今
皆さんがいる環境は
皆さん自身にとって
最善の環境ですか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]